are you a terrorist ever wondered what
you might be doing to get yourself
placed on one of those lists the South
Africa cables contain a secret document
shared by the Australian security
intelligence organization with other spy
agencies called indicators of extremists
and terrorists activities in it Aussie
spies tell their counterparts in the
online environment is a challenge
because potential terrorists can connect
with other extremists it urges its staff
other agencies and their foreign
counterparts to look out for lifestyle
changes among people especially Muslims
who become more religious one of the
things that shows intention capability
assisting strangers are someone new to
the community with accommodation or
financial arrangement so make sure not
to love thy neighbor also beware of
wanting to become the next Scorsese
because purchasing video making
equipment puts you on their radar
because that could be used to make a
martyr video unfortunately for anyone
wanting to visit their Pakistani grandma
travel to a conflict zone is suspicious
and will get you on the terror watch
list
under the section views extremists might
espouse denouncing Western countries or
governments particularly the United
States and Israel they say recurring
issues for many violent jihadists
include Israeli occupations of
Palestinian lands and perceived
oppression of the Palestinian people oh
by the way please use your cell phone so
you can be monitored like a civilized
person use of public telephones will
make you a suspect the agency is on the
lookout for those who engage in the
purchase possession or theft of chemical
biological radiological and explosive
materials which sounds fair I'm afraid
of those people oh and pesticides to
better let your weeds grow since you
can't buy them so to you that Muslim guy
living in the West who recently called
your mom on a public phone when your
cell phone battery died and you told her
how you helped that new guy Mahmoud
settle into the neighborhood and how you
just love that DSLR camera you recently
bought oh and then you mentioned you've
been trying everything to get rid of
that ant infestation in your basement
then you asked how your grandma in
Karachi is doing
said you hope to visit her soon we have
one word for you
run